hello and welcome to the reason live
stream I'm Zach Weissmuller I'm joined
today by my colleague Nick Gillespie hey
uh and today we're talking about Noster
a new decentralized social media and
Communications protocol and we'll
explain exactly what that means shortly
with the help of our two guests today uh
nvk the founder of the company coin
kites which offers a number of Bitcoin
related products a Bitcoin related
product developer uh and the host of the
Bitcoin review podcast hey nbk thanks
for having me guys
and uh will kazarin a Noster protocol
developer and creator of the app Damas
which was the first Noster based app to
make it onto the Apple Store and uh
which is my preferred client for
accessing Noster will thank you for
joining us
thanks for having me
so guys I wanted to talk about Noster uh
which is a relatively at least to me new
uh protocol that's that's openly
available uh because I've been
interested for a few years now in
multiple efforts to decentralize or
really re-decentralize the foundations
of the web uh and when I look at Noster
which to be clear is still in very early
days uh it's it's kind of exciting uh
and I I do get that feeling the kind of
you know Ron Paul it's happening meme
we'll see after this conversation
whether cold Waters poured on that but I
did think you know a good way to begin
would be to look back at an excerpt from
a piece I put together back in September
of 2019 called the decentralized web is
coming to kick off a conversation
what year was that again uh 2019. all
right so like a lifetime okay yeah well
so we'll see if you know four years
later or you know three and a half years
later if it's actually arrived uh and uh
so let's take a look at this clip and uh
I'd like I'd like to get your your
reactions and get into a conversation
about decentralizing the web Facebook
topping the global digital advertising
market last year we're seeing this
incredibly large company getting
involved in almost every area of
Commerce big Tech media companies
they're actively silencing what I'm
saying is we got to break these guys
apart you want to run a platform that's
fine you don't get to run a whole bunch
of the businesses
Google handles 88 of search traffic in
America Facebook has more than 2.4
billion active monthly users and it's
projected that half of U.S online retail
will go through Amazon by 2020. there
are calls from both sides of the aisle
to break up the tech Giants to strip
them of liability protections for what
others say on their platforms and to
impose new regulations that would stop
them from misusing the personal
information of their customers but
there's also a growing movement among
some of the web's pioneering thinkers
and software developers to come up with
technological solutions to countering
The Growing Power of Facebook Amazon
Twitter and Google the goal is to build
a new decentralized web Cory doctorow is
a science fiction author and tech
journalist at boingboing who's been
thinking and writing about the web since
it was introduced by Tim berners-lee in
the early 1990s berners-lee and other
web Pioneers Dr o points out intended
for their creation to be decentralized
and open source the Cyber utopian view
was not merely that sees the means of
information would make you free but that
failing to do so would put you in
Perpetual chains well there are a lot of
reasons to want a more decentralized
diffused pluralistic Internet it's hard
to imagine that anyone is competent to
make great decisions for two and a half
billion people
so does that what Corey Dr said there
have any resonance with either of you
and we can start with nvk and then will
uh you know in terms of what you're
interested and what's happening with
Noster
yeah so I think like the the initial
sort of like Web Two web three kind of
thing was all essentially VC scams
um and you know it was essentially a 16
Zed and Company trying to own the next
version of the web so it was not really
decentralized it just had new owners
um and uh you know Bitcoin happened
right about over a decade ago now and
Bitcoin is freedom money right and you
can't really do anything without Freedom
money uh you can't even build a
decentralized like internet or
communication without Freedom money
because otherwise you can't really do
anything
um even pay for the servers
um so
what uh what what gnoster wheel and Fiat
did uh that you know it was about two
years ago now will uh when it came out
uh is they created this incredibly
simple protocol
that uh that that is very good at
relaying information
and and being sort of like is like
distributed decentralized and it can
also be private uh it lives in all
spaces uh it's incredibly hard to kill
uh it sort of like resolves this problem
so you can have decentralized money and
decentralized communication so that
humans can sort of trade in peace right
uh there is no owners there's no company
uh same for Bitcoin same for an Oster
um this this two sort of this at least
how I see it the combination of the two
uh really sort of like came uh uh had
the Stars aligned uh for us to to build
a more free future for everybody
so will you you along with Fiat Jeff as
NPK uh mentioned there are one of the
protocol developers what was your
motivation for doing this and then we
can discuss a little further exactly
what it is we're talking about but first
I just want to know you know what is
what is the vision here
yeah I've always been interested in like
you know new and interesting protocols
you know Bitcoin really caught my eye
early on and you know I've always been
looking at trying to think of the ways
of getting back to like the early days
of the internet when everyone just it
wasn't like owned by corporations and
people just hung out and had fun
um and you know it was much more
decentralized back then because it was
much more focus on protocols so I've
always been interested in like how do
you apply you know protocols like do you
improve freedom on the internet
um so you know the first one that I
tried was Mastodon and Mastodon was like
this really cool idea where you could
you know spin up an instance
um and then join it and then hang out
with your friends
um but that we we started to see that
that um started there's a lot of cracks
in that design in the sense that any one
of those instance admins becomes like
their own little
um like they can just ban you and then
you have to start over so as I was
always looking for a way to like make
this kind of solve that issue where
um like that we have on Mastodon and
then eventually found Nostra and it got
me really intrigued it was really simple
and I just kind of dived in and and you
know and it's been amazing since then so
this might be a good spot to bring Nick
in because you know you mentioned
Mastodon Nick I know that you have
experimented a little bit with Mastodon
and there was you know a uh and a kind
of Exodus after Elon took over that that
seemed to be the big alternative and uh
some recent articles have shown a bit of
a drop off in recent months
um I I would like to hear from from you
will and and maybe nbk you know what it
is uh that is that differentiates Noster
from something like Mastodon but uh Nick
what do you think about you know the the
kind of initial Twitter Exodus uh
towards something like Mastodon yeah
well first of all I want to point out
that I as we were having this
conversation I realized I had just
tweeted out hey come and listen to all
of us talk about Noster and Mammoth
which is what I keep calling Mastodon in
my head and like I've officially my
father always used to I'm almost 60
years old so I'm [__] old but my
father would always refer it to Cheech
and Chong as Gucci gangao and I am like
totally in My Gucci Gango phase now
because I keep calling it Mammoth
um but uh yeah you know I I always saw
the people who were like and there were
a lot of journalists because Twitter one
of the one of the good things of bad
things about Twitter is that there's a
ton of journalists on it and they're oh
they were always like you know the
minute that Elon Musk took over they
were like oh you know what [__]
Twitter sucks this is a hellscape you
know I've got to get out of here I've
got to go to digital Canada which was
going to be Mastodon and then of course
like five of them left half of those
people came back after they realized
Twitter wasn't gonna disappear
um but I do you know my my questions for
you guys uh and I I guess just off the
bat like the promise of Mastodon was
that you could get to a place where
somebody like Elon Musk or Jack Dorsey
before him or or less those guys really
and like all of the faceless mid-level
managers and we've seen this in the
Twitter files who actually had it you
know had the opportunity to just say you
know what I don't like what this person
says I don't like what I think they
believe so I'm going to you know screw
them over something like Mastodon you
know gives you the the idea that you can
get elsewhere if you could just for this
particular moment and uh well maybe uh
because I think you were you were
leaning into this a little bit or
leading up to it it's like when you get
to Mastodon there are little islands of
community there that are more repressive
than anything outside of like North
Korea where there were there were whole
journalists who went to certain servers
or whatever and Mastodon to find out
that that came with an auto block list
so that they couldn't communicate with
anybody and nobody could see their [__]
um is that like the big flaw with
Mastodon and then how does Noster kind
of Route around that issue
yeah so
um like I was mentioning there's there's
a huge flaw in the sense that you join
an instance so I think nvk ran Bitcoin
hackers and it was like the only
instance that I was able to get on and
without because I I signed up to like
multiple different instances and I would
just say the word Bitcoin and there's
just so many Communists on that these
platforms I just instantly get kicked
off and I get banned so I have to start
over and build my follower list again so
I'm like I found a home at Bitcoin
hackers uh but then the issue was you
know every other instance just banned
Bitcoin hackers it was really just you
know we only had a small community it
never really and it's pretty crude right
I mean yeah so they're not like actually
going I mean you know at least that old
you know social clubs in New York or San
Francisco they would kind of look at you
and pretend to give you a once over half
the time this is all just done based on
your handle or what what identifiers you
put in your profile so we opened
bitcoinhackers.org just to in case
Twitter sort of started kicking off
kicking out bitcoiners uh this was while
back I can't remember what was the
reason but there was something that was
going on I think a lot of bitcoiners
were getting shut up banned on Twitter
uh because Twitter was being run by
commies right and so we all started like
you know joining master and I'm like
okay maybe maybe this instance is like
how we finally sort of like Get Enough
people a critical mass outside of
Twitter uh as at least a backup uh
and uh you know my my instance had no no
moderation right I'm like listen you
guys are all adults please don't do
criminal things you know talk about
whatever you want
um and that caused the whole Mastodon
Universe to just block my instance like
so essentially every single Mastodon
server out there blocked it
um and we had no communication with the
outside that Universe Bank
um and then I realized like oh wait
there's also people joining my instance
who I actually really dislike and I
don't want to host their data so I went
and I deleted one of them and I was like
okay great I don't want to be benevolent
dictator either right like this is not a
row I want I don't want to host your
data
um so uh when I learn about Noster it
was like a little bit too early and and
you know these guys were playing that I
was too busy with Bitcoin
um and then I think I came back a few
months ago I was like okay holy crap
like this thing is really sort of like
now the clients work wheels that almost
it was like this is great
um and uh I think Jack joined uh as well
and you know like he he sort of did a
bit of an infusion of uh of uh cash and
uh and and attention and uh and that
project sort of like taken off like it's
working
um and uh it's been a it's been a blast
we built a like a relay over the
holidays we survived the the Chinese
spam influx
um you know Project's still going can
you uh uh nvk can you explain then and
and layman's terms because like I I like
being an end user of this kind of stuff
but I really don't [__] understand a
lot of it but what is different about
hosting a relay on Noster versus running
an instance on uh Mass I was going to
say sure I think let's call it Mammoth
yeah uh so on Mammoth on Mastodon
um it's fully centralized like fully
centralized I have the instance I have
the domain all your data sits on my
server and then they have uh like a few
sort of like apis in their protocol for
you to sort of like push to other
instances they want to see your content
right so it's like there is a very thin
layer of how you can sort of like
interconnect that that uh I'm
oversimplified but there's a very sort
of thin very narrow way way of you sort
of like to transport those those uh
toots as they call it those notes tweets
between the instances right that are
okay with each other but users have
absolutely no freedom and no control
other other than to choose to join
exactly instance or that you're just
picking a new dictator right
um yeah so maybe
from this angle in the sense that you
know you don't actually what nvk was
saying you don't actually own your data
because all the data and all and all the
keys for the data is all signed by the
instance admin so that gives them the
power to just like they own your data
right so it's just it's kind of a Google
button a smaller scale but with Nostra
every piece of data that you create on
the network is signed by your private
key and then you can take and so in some
sense that gives you really strong
ownership over all of your posts all of
your contact lists and it allows you to
really easily move to different relays
like I couldn't you can't really easily
move from one Mass on instance to
another because you don't control the
keys you don't control the data the
minute you have to control the keys of
all your posts and all of you of all
your speech you can I'll replicate it to
different relays so it's much more
flexible than Mastodon in that sense and
it gives you like the user more power
the information is transportable by the
user I mean it really lives in many
relays and you choose you can even have
your own private relay just for the
backup
um any and you can also transport your
identity between clients so you know
like on a Bitcoin wallet right when you
reload your seed in a different wallet
the money just show up there is the same
idea with this uh if you load your keys
into a new client you're instantly
accessing all your information that was
already there
um and also all the all the the the
communication is public right so there
is no deleting there is no backseats uh
there is no censorship uh because you're
always going to find a different relay
uh uh to relay your comments and maybe
store them temporarily or permanently
um I was pulling up this uh this Snowden
tweets Snowden is I would say probably
one of if not the pious profile user of
Noster at this point you know maybe Jack
Dorsey
um but he describes uh this difference
between a platform and a protocol and
everyone involved with Nostra is very uh
you know insistent that this is a
protocol not a platform
um he says a pla if a platform is a silo
a protocol is a river no one owns it and
everyone is free to swim is that an
accurate characterization
yeah I think I think he really hits the
nail on the head in that sense it's like
you know platforms they they control the
data they they Define who's allowed to
access the data at what time and and if
you get kicked out then you can't you
know it's a side load and you can't get
to it but you know in this case it's
more of like a river where anyone kind
of jump in the river swim down and
everyone can kind of be involved um so I
really like that analogy
um but yeah it's definitely more of a
protocol than any than a platform so can
I ask real quick uh just follow up with
the metaphor of the river and I'm
thinking now of like you know the lazy
river at uh at an amusement park
everybody's kind of floating along in
their inner tubes how does Noster work
as a protocol to make sure that like
things you know there aren't too many
people you know clogging everything up
uh Etc
and yeah so this is actually a big issue
um because you know I run probably one
of the biggest relays on the domus relay
and it's wide open to the public and
it's just getting spammed to hell
um so it's like that's just that's the
analogy there's like everyone's kind of
clogged and crammed in and you look at
the global feed it's just like spam spam
um so that's a big issue and when one
way you can get around this is a paid
relays um so there's a bunch of paid
relays where you just have 10 000
Satoshi
um entry fee and it just you know and
then kind of wait like and only people
with those keys can actually post on the
relay so that's one way to kind of clear
up the congestion when you say spam how
do you identify spam and how how do you
categorize that as a different type of
information than you know an actual
meaningful communication
yeah it's usually just like them
spamming the same message over and over
and over it's not you can tell it's your
noise yeah it's nice visit my book or
website visit my poker website visit my
poker website it's very obvious well I I
mean I guess the I'm what I'm I'm
interested about is that you you guys
were talking a lot and this is you know
I I think I uh my first email account or
online account email account was like 89
or 90. so it was way back it was
pre-spam uh you know then there was this
the kind of spam Revolution and a bunch
of people particularly in a kind of
libertarian or ancap world were kind of
like hey don't you know don't be so fast
to call something spam uh because the
original you know the original problem
was were commercial messages that were
being sent to people via email so could
you walk a little bit through perhaps
the you know the pre uh you know the
pre-web internet and why that was more
decentralized even if it was being
hosted you know up through some point in
the 80s or or I guess by the end of the
80s I think the government was out of it
but why was the you know the the era of
Usenet which a lot of old people uh you
know talk about this was a glorious
moment of decentralization
um and then how how did the web or how
did the internet become the web and get
centralized in in which seems to be what
we're trying to get away from right now
uh do you want me to take that yeah go
ahead
yeah so the way I see it is that you
know the web is a great is that is a
great platform and I don't know we're
kind of you know abusing terms here but
you know foreign people started to build
silos on top of this like landscape
which is the web so the web is is
decentralized you anyone can spin up a
server
um but the kind of the main issue is
that
you know how do these like silos talk to
each other right so if you set up like
Gmail or YouTube or all these different
platforms that you know they're all
independent so yeah in theory like the
underlying substrates decentralized but
the things we're building in this
landscape are not and they don't talk to
each other
um so when I think of decentralization
or at least like the redecentralization
of the web I see like how do we connect
these silos together and how do we make
all these apps that we're building
interoperable so I think Master is like
one of the the one of these protocols
that can actually link these you know
disparate silos togethers which is
pretty fascinating to me yeah and while
we're talking about this I'm just going
to pull up this so the way what you do
is you sign up you you create a key pair
so you have a public key and a private
key and then you can use that to access
kind of I guess what we call the nostril
network is that I don't know but uh you
can use different clients and all of the
uh all of your followers all your posts
you can see all of it no matter what you
you log into and so I'm just going to
pull up here I just kind of did a
screenshot of multiple tabs I've got one
this one called astral there's one
called snort.social there's one called
Iris and when you switch between them
you see me switching between them it's
the same feed uh the same people all my
followers are portable so I just wanted
to have that as a kind of demonstration
as as we're talking about that that
concept and then of course uh you know
this is Damas which was the first uh app
to get through the store to allow you to
to through the Apple store to get um
connected to the nostril Network what
was that like uh will
um both building that uh and then
getting past kind of the the Apple
programmers did the decentralized
aspects make that you know more
difficult than a typical app
yeah so it was actually a very long
struggle with the Apple review
um people because they're not used to
like a concept of a decentralized social
media app they don't really understand
what that is so so a lot of the time to
be like okay well we need you we need
you to add a feature that allows you to
like block a user and or to de-platform
someone I'm like I literally can't do
that this protocol does not allow that
and they're like I'm like so I so all I
can really do is add blocking features
so you can users can block other users
but you know I'm just a client I have no
ability to tell a relay to like kick a
user off right I'm just talking to like
the silo or these these relays
um so that was a big struggle and I and
I don't know how it got through I
eventually just kept resubmitting it and
then it finally went through there's not
like there's like from what I understand
is there's it's a kind of like a magic
uh to get on the App Store but
eventually I got on and then within two
days um I was banned in China because
like the CCP I guess got wind of it
pretty quickly and they're like oh I
gotta stop this but it was it's been an
interesting experience seeing it just
going through the whole process how many
uh how many downloads have you uh seen
so far
uh we're up to about 250
um it went up to 24 000 in Mainland
mainland China in like a day and then
that before it got cut off so if they
didn't cut off China I bet it would have
would have been much much higher if when
you say okay so it's cut off so uh
people in uh mainland China can't get it
anymore but the people who have it can
they continue to use it or has it been
rendered in operative
they can just use it outside of Damas
and outside of uh the app store right
like I remember when the relays were
getting bombarded with Chinese traffic
uh because the App Store did open there
uh that the the downloads on the store
for for China dropped uh but the the
relay that we run the the Chinese
traffic is sort of like remain the same
yeah
um so that's the thing right you don't
need the same client it doesn't matter
if CCP doesn't like it anymore right I
mean people who just read vpns or Thor
and get around it because the
information uh network is the same right
the client is just sort of like you know
one more nice sort of experience and
shapes how you absorb it how you
interact with it but the information
system is the same much more much like
the internet right or TCP like I mean
the stuff is just flowing through
um you just find another way of tapping
into it and I'm I'm sorry I'm I'm
speaking up for the other you know the
one other person listening to this other
than me who needs this kind of analogy
but then is the client I mean the client
is kind of like Outlook used to be or
something like it it's a lot it allows
you to pull your email into like form
that you can organize Etc
I do like female analogy though in that
because yeah because the email is a
protocol right yes an email is vertical
so the main difference is so it's a
really good analogy because you can have
multiple different clients so there's a
Gmail client that's a client things like
that um so Thomas would be one client
but the difference between email and
Austria is that you know in some sense
the the information is siled within it's
kind of hard to like you know you know
pull down your data and push it to
another email server so that's kind of
the main difference is that the data is
much more flexible can flow much better
but it's very similar to analogy I think
you know remember using that where you
have you know multiple servers hosting a
lot of the same data yeah it's more like
that so you have to use that sort of
client and then you have just multiple
servers you can pull the same data from
uh Union can also push to different
servers
this relays right that would also sort
of like they can mirror each other they
can send uh to different uh other relays
so you're not tight it's not like Hub
and spoke you're not tied back to a
single point uh your client can talk to
multiple places or RSS same idea right
like you can pull from different places
and back to the China example for a
second because I think it's worth
lingering up on since that is you know
the the prime example of an
authoritarian very powerful Authority
saying second only to uh Mark Zuckerberg
in Facebook this is not allowed I'm
putting up here just right now the the
notice that will posted uh that it his
app had been banned in China and you see
Snowden commenting down there smells
like fear
um but the reality is you know when I go
to the global feed which is like the
kind of fire hose of everything that
anyone is posting from anywhere in the
world uh to Noster you still see like a
ton of uh Chinese posts it's almost
maybe even you know half of the posts uh
have you know Chinese characters on them
so clearly that's some evidence that
this protocol is fairly censorship
resistant yes
it's yeah it's going to be really hard
for them to shut down all the relays
because for instance because I was
asking some people in China I'm like do
you guys are you guys running your own
relays when they told me yes so there's
there could be like a sub Network that
we don't even see that they're using
within their country and that's so like
that's one that's a big issue is when
you go across the firewall apparently
then
um they can start tracking things but if
they're actually running their own
relays within their local communities
then they can communicate um and we
wouldn't even see that right so yeah I
mean so
um think about it this way
um you don't really have like a global
global feed right like it's not like
there's a single Source a single River
it's more like a pluvial system right so
you have like multiple rivers and you're
all connected to each other uh and and
they can change paths too right so if
somebody puts a stop in one you can
reroute that to some other relay and you
can have say like a mirror relay or a
bridge relay uh that uses some other
sort of form of communication uh uh that
is not like the main internet uh for you
to to sort of create this interactivity
between the two uh mostly because this
protocol is so sort of like simple and
contained it's it's pretty clever so the
thing that you you start to think about
then is you know what are the choke
points that are that that governments
are going to try to use it I mean it
seems to me that the the relays
themselves would be that the target like
like there's going to be malicious
actors right there's going to be people
putting child abuse up there or you know
scam type Financial schemes trying to
like the you know funnel money to
terrorists or whatever and then the
government's going to get interested are
they going to go and start shutting down
the individual relays that Host this
stuff like is the Relay operator going
to be the choke point or the person held
liable
um or and is there any way to guard
against that and make sure you're not
going to get screwed over as the person
that's hosting this content it's just
like you know flag Theory right same
idea it's the same idea for Bitcoin
mining is you know as long as there is
an economic incentive and that's why
sort of like the Bitcoin start to play
into this somebody is going to relay
that message somewhere else right so yes
they can they can ask Amazon to take
down a relay here they can ask you know
her so like to take down a relay in
Germany or whatever but you you can't
you can't block them all and they can
all have a copy of the information so
this one is going to be a tough one for
governments to try to stop I mean you
know you look at all fact compliance uh
for Bitcoin mind blocks right they OPAC
cannot oh [__] is the stuff that it's
essentially like the treasury saying hey
this is a terrorist transaction you
can't accept it you can't mine it right
sanctions violating yeah thanks yeah so
most of the most of the miners like
still do it right so it's no different
than this I mean like half the world
doesn't give a crap about what your
government locally cares so they will
relay uh and you can attach that
economic sort of uh interest or
incentive so that they they have a
reason to do so
but does that push people out of I mean
like you guys are you're living in in
the developed World in oecd countries
you know if they come after you isn't
that going to have a chilling effect on
uh you know on people who are either
developing clients or or other Pro you
know programs that lay on top of the
protocols Etc
um and if they go to Amazon I mean like
if you know if if the US government if
the SEC or the FTC or the FBI
says hey you know what you're harboring
something and you have this you know you
you make a lot of money having uh you
know web servers but you make even more
money uh and you have your freedom you
know in the Amazon retail stuff is isn't
that enough pressure to kind of squeeze
the type of TR you know the type of
activity you're talking about out out of
the developed world how how's the war
against turrets going how's the war
against drugs going you know these guys
don't really achieve what they're trying
right so I mean pirate base do online
um oh sure like I mean I'm a law abiding
citizens I mean they don't but like yeah
I mean they don't you know open source
yeah okay I I no and I'm saying like you
know I I I guess this isn't a question
of whether you're right or wrong but
then it becomes you know the the amount
of workarounds and the and the
deadweight loss of working around stuff
because you know the fact is is the you
know I was just talking about this with
uh some people the other night the DEA
The Drug Enforcement Administration
actually hosts a site where they put out
the street price of drugs you know an
inflation-adjusted terms they you know
for the past 50 years they've been
interdicting this stuff the price goes
down in real dollars and the pot
thing but they still arrest you know a
million people a year for you know
simple possession of pot or something
like that so it's always going to be
about selective enforcement right this
guy's great broad laws and then they
essentially only enforced against the
people that they don't like with the
current government in place right uh
thankfully flag Theory sort of resolves
a lot of this problems can I also ask
just uh and this was something I think
mvk you uh brought up uh when you were
uh running your uh little uh personal
dictatorship on Mastodon
um you know
it it remains it's it's a kind of
principle of of free association and in
many ways you know the the the kind of
grammar of the internet the DNA of the
internet in a lot of ways you know even
if it comes out of massive defense
spending on some level is very
libertarian part of voluntary
Association is that people can shut down
like they can choose not to associate
with certain people yeah I mean really
yeah yeah just just get off the relay or
or you know don't like block people on
your own personal client you just can't
prevent them from talking so that's I
mean that that is a great worker app
right instead of saying like Okay we're
not going to let you talk to anybody
it's just I don't have to deal with you
which seemed to be one of the you know
what are the promises of Twitter I was
always amazed when people are you know
like all you have to do to never hear
from somebody again is to block them or
mute them or whatever but people were
like no that's not good enough I want to
make sure that's because they want to
shut them off yeah right we all had to
deal with this for the App Store
submission yeah and so how did you do
that well did you say because that's one
of the things that the apps will say
like that you it would I mean and it's
worse on Apple I guess than it is for
Android stores but you you have to kind
of show that people can't use this for
criminal Behavior or if there is
Criminal Behavior going on there'll be
sanctions for that right
yeah I mean ultimately they just want to
make sure that their users on their
platform have a good experience and
obviously if you just go into the wild
west of Nostra you know even though it's
like it is limited to like 17 plus and
that's the rating on the app there's but
there's still kids who download these
apps and if they they go into the global
feed and see porn like that's not a good
experience so I think Apple's just
trying to guard against those scenarios
so all I can really do is just do the
best I can in terms of like trying to
hide bad content like I blurred photos
from people you don't follow
um I have this feature yeah where you
block people and you can always like
yeah unsubscribe from the relay to like
not see that the stuff in that relay so
that's the best I can really do because
and I just try to convince Apple that
this is all I could do like I Can't Ban
people so yeah
yeah that's just how the world works I
mean I mean you know like you
you can't prevent people from talking
right and and we're creating networks
like Bitcoin and Noster where we
essentially uh enforce that sort of like
naturalness of the world which is people
can do whatever they want if you don't
want to see it just close your eyes
right right you can't shut people up uh
in this system no and you sh you
shouldn't be able I mean so this is
where you're hearkening back obviously
this is a very forward-looking protocol
and system but you're looking back to
the origin points uh you know when when
you know anybody watching this I mean if
I can read uh uh John Perry Barlow's
Declaration of Independence and
cyberspace you would think that's not
just from the 90s you know it's not just
from like 25 30 years ago it's from a
different it's an alternative timeline
from man in the High Castle or something
like that but that's kind of I mean what
I I find really exciting about what
you're doing is that it's it's
channeling that energy of like okay
we're we are actually in a new and
different space that has different
potential and we're actually going to
run with that as opposed to immediately
try to revert back to turn the internet
or the World Wide Web into broadcast TV
Circa 2000.
yeah and um you know the the culture the
those first principles that this has
been built upon I think has attracted
um at least as the first adopters a
certain type of user and created a
certain culture that I want to get into
uh in a minute but I also want to bring
first in some of the audience questions
and if you have questions about this
conversation feel free to drop them in
the chat we'll we'll try to bring them
up uh one is uh omarto pizzas what
happened China used to be cool
um uh Alexander Jerry says you choose
the relays what makes a trustworthy
relay how does someone know it's not
going to USSR sorry I mean Russia or
China so is that a concern pick about
personal responsibility that's the world
we're building right it's uh no master
nodes no master relay uh so you know
like do your own research
it's your problem yeah fair enough yeah
not sure is a very public uh a very
public protocol so anything you
broadcast will guarantee you know it'll
go it'll be everywhere so
um especially yeah yeah
would you talk a little bit about the
the non-delete function because that's
you know one of the big things that
people were you know crying for Elon
Musk to implement was you know an edit
button on Twitter and things like that
people sent their tweets to auto
destruct or you know they uh you know
and and Twitter got rid of the thing
where you could save people delete
deleted tweets and things like that how
important is that you know this is a
this all is going on your permanent
record you know like they used to
threaten Us in high school and stuff
like that how important is that and when
do you think you'll be rethinking that
so Thomas actually used to have um
delete in the at least on the web
version when I had the web version
um and that's all well and good but in
some sense it's unenforceable because
you could you could send like hey I want
this message deleted to all the relays
but some relay could be like no I don't
want to delete it and so it doesn't
really delete anything like so
um that's kind of the biggest issue
um but I started thinking about it and I
think it's actually
although this is kind of like it's a
controversial idea but I think it's kind
of increasing the Integrity on the
network like you can't just just say
whatever you want and then delete it and
like take it back it's like you actually
have to think and like and not just
blurt out the stupid stuff so I I think
it's actually healthier for public
discourse and that's not leading to
people just choosing not to say anything
because that's right yeah um but you
know like on the internet you can't
delete anyways right every time somebody
deletes something you get Streisand
effect so you know can we just be
grown-ups here and just say stuff you
stand by and then listen you make a
mistake I make a lot of spout mistakes
right you just you know do it again uh
then network does support a note that
refers to another note saying hey that
was deleted so please use this new node
you know they'll be useful in
non-contentious situations right so say
for example you're using Noster to
create a long pot like you're crazy
you're using NASA to replace a medium
for example right or or sub stack very
doable somebody already dealed it's a
habla.news
um
you know you can create a new note that
just replace the post you had there
linked so that you you know fixed your
bullet points or whatever uh in in that
sense yes but you can't use uh you can't
use delete to sort of like forget gdpr
is hopeless yeah so I mean nvk is really
uh you know leaning into the kind of
Freedom responsibility like uh being
connected and that that that's uh and
it's a very it's very like Bitcoin view
of the world you know you gotta have
self-sovereignty over your own Keys it's
your response if I may it's also what I
what I like if I'm really appealing
about it and you guys are talking
obviously you're working at the level of
coding and everything but a lot of this
is kind of you know really philosophical
but it's an iterative process so that
you know we all make mistakes we all
make typos big and small and we
shouldn't be ashamed of that in a way
it's it's a better world where there is
our past that we we can see and learn
from and renounce right yeah you know
because everybody is naked yeah
yeah and with lowers lowers the uh the
fear and anxiety about being naked and
possibly the desire to stay in shape
which could be and understand you know
consequence there's nothing stopping us
from just adding an edit note like like
I think that's fine if you see a
revision history of like spelling
mistakes like this we can add that but
like you just can't delete it so but I I
would say that that's always been the
the trade-off it seems for
decentralization is it it puts more
responsibility on the user does that
concern you at all in terms of adoption
because like one one example that came
to my mind when I was signing up for
this is like okay I am now in charge of
the this private key and it but somehow
gets lost or someone else gets it and I
build you know thousands of followers
then there's no you know Noster customer
support that's gonna you know bail me
out here is there is is that
um a problem is it an is that is that
specific situation first of all
insurmountable and then just the idea
that there's no
um you know customer support uh is that
gonna really limit the growth potential
of something like this there is a very
good Community first and foremost so
there is customer support it's just not
like a corporate customer support uh
people will help you
um now the other thing is I mean there
is work being done in key rotation key
delegation so this is just sort of like
it's early uh uh it's just a challenge
but you know like eventually we're going
to have means for you to have better Key
Management let's put it this way so uh
losing Keys won't be the end of the
world you might just have to tell the
world that he was lost and hopefully
enough really see it and and then you
know
um so you're building out these kind of
networks of trust would be the solution
there um of like trusted relays
uh no it's more like a it's more like a
cryptographic solution to the problem
like it's very similar to when you lose
a key to important computers you can
essentially sign that you lost and sort
of like with another key that's the
parent key for that uh it can get very
complicated fast but the idea is uh you
would have means of of sort of changing
keys and and sort of like affording to
lose some keys and there's a few things
that domus is gonna is doing and is
going to do one is that it automatically
like saves your key into your password
manager so you know it really strongly
encourages you to do that
um in the future we might have an option
where you can just um put in your email
and like maybe a password and then it'll
just encrypt your thing to your email so
you can always recover it that way so
there's a lot of just like practical
user experience things we can do just to
make it
um just make it like less of a pain if
you lose your key and and then the
lastly like I've seen this happen all
people what you're describing this has
happens all the time and usually what
they do is it's like hey this I you know
well I guess that in that particular
case it's usually because they're
leaking their private key and they
usually have to do another post like hey
I'm moving to this key but yeah losing
your key kind of sucks I it happened to
be a few times in the very early days
I will say it's part of course it is
interesting like that there's already a
verification system so you can you know
get your coveted check mark without
having to you know beg a company to give
it to you uh and there's or pay them
eight dollars a month to retain it what
is
um and it seems to rely on this concept
called a nip uh what what is that how
how is the network you know modifiable
in that way
yeah so nips are just they're called
nostril Improvement proposals very
similar to the Bitcoin
um or is that what it's called yeah yeah
not so Improvement proposals okay
um I think I should know that but yeah
it's just the way that you extend the
network like anyone can make a nib and
you know it's not we don't have Global
consensus like Bitcoin in the sense that
if we're trying to suggest to change the
network that everyone has to agree
anyone can just extend it um because the
way that the nodes work is that they're
really flexible so anyone can create a
new note type which is like a different
kind and then you can just have a custom
application that does things like maybe
do like a ride sharing app or
um so that the notes themselves are very
flexible and that allows great
interoperability between all the clients
because at any point if someone makes a
new app let's say a ride sharing app
then I can just pull down those notes
into Thomas and I can like show like
your route on your endomisible I don't
know there's so this this increased like
flexibility between
um applications is like the most
powerful thing that we actually have
really talked about yet so one of the
ways that corporate uh America has sort
of like captured the internet is through
C8 certificates right so when you have
your browser say SSL encrypted then sort
of like all the the main browser
distributor said hey we're going to
force you now to be SSL encrypted
because it's for your own safety right
right so that you can't be men in the
middle which is kind of true but uh with
that they also introduce this thing
which is essentially like a master list
of of approved uh uh as uh certificate
authorities right uh and and with that
they essentially removed the capacity of
most people uh to self-sign their own
certificate for their own website so
essentially you have to give Amazon
cloudflare and this big corporations uh
the keys to the kingdom they have to be
the ones who sign this
um they are the ones who can see the
traffic in between uh so the NSA gets
their piece
um so
essentially with with Noster now what's
really cool is you self-sign right your
um your verification by having your
public key under a domain that you own
uh you know you're still sort of like
you know at the mercy of the DNS uh
servers registrars and all that stuff
but at least now if like it's seriously
like a five minute guide any person uh
even nick uh can go there uh and and set
up you know his uh Nick at galispy.com
right
um I think it's gonna take me at least
10 minutes but yeah well let's let's
talk about that Nick you you did set up
your Nostra recently what was that
experience like before it was it was
really kind of painful I mean I sort of
felt like I you know I I got a glimpse
of what Alzheimer's is like
um and Zach helped me through it I you
know I had tried to do it a while ago
when I first heard about this when uh I
guess when Dorsey left Twitter and he
was then started talking about Nostra uh
because I like that idea of that I have
an account again I was going to call it
Mammoth on Mastodon I have I ended up
making two accounts because it was very
confusing
um but yeah I mean I what it is is the
Nostra ethos always going to be kind of
inscrutable to newcomers or is there
going to become a kind of AOL of Nostra
or or or is it is it you know I uh years
and years ago I I ghost wrote a uh God
this was in the early 90s I ghost wrote
a uh book chapter for a then Sprint
executive who was talking about how we
will know that computers have fully
penetrated our Consciousness when you
take it out of the box and you don't
need an instruction manual to start it
it's like a toaster you just you know
how to use it when you pull it out of
the box and that's partly design changes
but also like Society you know you I
mean like people know how to start cars
now even if they don't have any idea of
like what's under a car or anything like
that so could you talk a little bit
about that and and I guess we haven't
gotten to this we were going to uh Zach
put together a kind of great list of
like the the you know lying that nostril
people are using it it's like I you know
what the [__] are they talking about and
that's part of a new thing right that
you're learning a new language
so but
yeah yeah so like you know it's early
right it's very early it's early in this
protocol it's early in this technology
uh you know of course it's like the
Nerds are going to come in first because
they know how to do stuff right they
know how to code yeah uh but but then
comes will and and sort of like you know
releases this this app that like any
person any person can just download
click a button and use like I mean if
you're not importing keys or doing
anything you're just downloading from
the store and starting the app works
it's actually easier because you don't
have to create a password and username
right so you know like I don't know like
I don't see where the difficulty is
anymore if you're using so these apps
yeah the biggest issue right now is like
there's certain things that users expect
like being able to set a profile picture
which is like surprisingly not an
obvious thing on this protocol because
we there's actually no ways to there's
no way to host media like video or
images on Nostra it's all just text so
you have to kind of go elsewhere to like
put your images on and the client like I
mean I could do that eventually gonna do
that where damage just has their own
image host and you can upload your
profile picture but those are just like
ux improvements that we can make over
time it just makes it easier for users
so yeah so yeah and I I was using Iris
on my computer and that that was very
simple actually all of that kind of
stuff becomes very simple very quickly
yeah that's coming to IOS as well by the
way uh yeah he has a test flight already
yeah yeah I I agree that that's a very
it's quite a seamless uh and
well-designed desktop client I've been
using that one on desktop
um you know we've been mentioning that
this is still early days uh these are
some this is a guy who runs a site that
I guess monitors the relays to try to
you know deduce how many user daily
active users there are on Noster the
blue line
um is what they call high quality Pub
Keys writing events
um something happened on February 16th
that caused you know more than
484 Pub keys to write events which just
means it's just accounts posting to
Noster you know over 400 almost 500 000
times the total users
profiles with bios the blue line so a
little bit above 500 000 users uh which
is probably the right line right the
right line to be looking at to get a
decent estimate of like you know real
people using Noster um by just by
comparison you know Facebook is over 2
billion uh users so it's you know early
days not a big fish yet uh but that
creates an opportunity for this
interesting culture to arise because
it's a very self-selected group of
people Jack Dorsey says Noster is
Counter Culture today and has the
potential to stay that way the open and
wildly decentralized development model
keeps it Punk
um so that that's that's an interesting
assertion because he's saying you know
he's he's kind of saying the medium is
the message here and that just the very
design of Noster is going to keep it
that way it's going to keep that that
punk ethos in definitely do you think
that's right or is it going to kind of
evolve new Norms as the user base if and
when the user base grows
um so so like you know I hate like sort
of like bringing Bitcoin all the time to
this but
um you know when you have technologies
that the culture can't be shaped the
culture can't be enforced right you end
up having the the first comers always to
be sort of like self-selecting uh
freedom-loving people right because it's
just it's just part of the nature of the
protocol itself right
um I find that noser to be very much the
same way it has that sort of like BBS
after dark Vibes you know it's it's like
Good Vibes it's the people who are into
it now
um you know culture does tend to dilute
over time but because you can have sort
of like this sort of like in-groups out
groups you can have this sort of like
segregated spaces right so you can have
private relays right or like invite-only
relays that that still sort of interact
with the rest of the Universe
um
you know you can preserve that thing
that is pretty awesome I mean like
Bitcoins but like over 10 years old now
and we still have you know end caps
having you know a space to talk uh so so
it's pretty cool that way here's an
example of I think this post from Odell
uh really distills down the Noster
culture uh it's gonna make no sense to
anybody who has not been on the network
Pura Vita stay humble and stack sets and
then kind of hang hang loose Emoji
underneath there it says PV hang loose
uh what does any of that mean
go ahead will uh you integrated into the
client so Jack has had a huge influence
on at least the dumbest client so you
know so right when he started joining he
would do the the Shaka the Hang Loose
Emoji to every person who joined So
eventually we changed the like button to
uh which was the heart on Twitter we
changed it to the Chaka so it's like
because it makes more sense and and Jack
agreed is like well you know it's just
anyway
um so you know the culture is kind of
like getting is evolving and we're kind
of integrating into the client over time
and Pure Vita I think is a term from uh
you know
Costa Rica or something where it just
means Pure Life and it's I don't know it
just it kind of took it just it took off
and now we use up everything and so it's
got that uh you know it's a positive
attitude faster like laid back vibe to
it that's uh and it's I mean it seems
like a a bit of surfer culture kind of
thrown in in a positive way you know I
think we should definitely bring up to
this audience that uh Jack was uh like a
Walmart greeter uh uh for uh for like
pretty much everybody who joined on the
first on the on the big wave that came
in what was it three four three months
ago two months ago uh it was it was fun
to see uh he didn't say to you the fact
that the founder of Twitter is certainly
it's he's got to be the most high
profile backer he certainly put you know
the most money uh into the project what
does Jack dorsey's involvement mean for
Noster
it's validating right I mean you know
we'll like you closely like more working
oh yeah um
yeah it's interesting because you know
he he said this is what this was a big
post that he did on Austria he's like
this is what Twitter felt like at 5 000
users but better and so I feel like Jack
this is kind of what he always wanted to
build is an open Free Speech protocol
that's like real time it reminds him a
lot like it's nostalgic to him from the
early days of Twitter when
um because nachos actually was very much
like what it felt like in the early days
of Twitter more real time and like open
protocol open apis so I think he's like
yeah nostalgic and he just wants to you
know he wants to like take that ex what
he had in the early days of Twitter and
he and then relive it and not sure and
build it out so it's kind of cool
yeah sorry guys like what's really cool
is that like he is contributing a lot
financially too to a lot of projects uh
and and like but the community itself is
doing as well uh we actually have a
website bound sir sr.org where people
put bounties uh for features and
projects and people are building like
this habla dot news and uh and there
were others so uh so if you're a Dev out
there watching this do do go check out
and participate a couple of years ago at
the Bitcoin Miami Conference uh Alex
gladson of Human Rights Foundation
interviewed Jack Dorsey who I you know I
think I I find Jack Dorsey to be the
most inspiring and very Tech leader that
we have and he was talking about how
Twitter never should become the platform
where people speak but it should you
know the the internet or there should be
a Twitter of Twitter's there should just
be you know a kind of a Utopia of
Utopias
um you know it's a very libertarian very
dispersed very decentralized things two
questions part of the power of Twitter
and this is also true of Facebook and
before it was true of you know AOL uh
back when it had a Walled Garden is that
it is a place where lots and lots of
people are and is there is there a
necessary trade-off between this size of
the audience which gives things a lot of
power and a lot of meaning and the
ability to kind of control your
experience or to have maximum freedom is
that just is that just a trade-off
that's one question and then the second
one is there a way that you can see or
or has Jack Dorsey talked about this of
integrating Nostra with Twitter so that
you can you you can participate in
Twitter without having to worry about
you know Elon Musk as a sugar Spa you
know blood sugar Spike and blocks you
forever and ever and like oh you know
the past 10 years or 15 years of your
[__] life is just locked away from
you forever
um so so like first of all protocol
shouldn't be companies right they should
be an open protocol that anybody Builds
on top
um yes Twitter could create a client
could create a relay tomorrow and I mean
like Peter could literally push all the
tweets into a relay as the author or
they could you know go really the proper
route and create like a key pair for
each user and sort of like go that
direction so yes it's totally possible
that they could participate in this but
at least in my view like most people
don't want freedom most people just want
a better sell so right you have to give
people tools for them to sort of like
censor the things they want to censor
for themselves and you know and we're
going to see this we're gonna see relays
where it's like I don't know like a
PG-13 right a PG-13 relay where you know
you follow those guidelines and you're
okay if your kids go on that relay and
and that's sort of like the the moral
set that you have and but but the key
here is choice right uh it's not
preventing the people who do what
freedom to have that freedom
and just going back to your your first
question about like you know there is
that power of that Global Network and
you can kind of you know tap in anyone
to have conversations with anyone but
we're also starting to see how that is
not always have the the most positive
effects like there's a lot of anger on
Twitter whether that's you know these
algorithms that are you know making
people like fight each other we might
not necessarily even want to interact to
begin with and sometimes you're kind of
being you're forced to to like click the
you know the anger bait on on Twitter so
maybe it makes sense that we have we
distill our networks into smaller sub
communities and maybe those are
represented by different relays and they
overlap in some in in the ways that you
might want to overlap and like and if
you want if you're if you're a part of
two communities maybe you join that one
relay and you join the other relay and
you see both in the in your in your
client but people who don't want to see
that other community they don't have to
join that relay so we might see like
smaller community-based relays in the
future so can I ask just to kind of
follow up on that issue because you know
part of this is technology and protocols
and what is possible but the other part
is kind of what is permissible not
simply by governments but by you you
know a kind of uh you know Global
Zeitgeist or or a regional Zeitgeist and
uh you know mvk I think you were saying
you know most people don't want freedom
um you know that makes me think of
people you know like her Herbert Marcus
and one-dimensional man or going back to
Eric from Escape from Freedom there's a
persistent you know you know sense which
is not you know completely off base that
most people don't not only do they not
want freedom for themselves they don't
want freedom for other people and so
uh you know how much of tech policy that
we're seeing as you know both from
government levels in terms of Regulation
but then also within companies are
coming from the fact that you know all
of us are in some part of libertarian
world or you know Ann capistan
um how much of it is that we are in a
moment now where people are like oh I've
seen beautiful beautiful freedom I don't
want it for myself and I don't want it
from you and like you know how do we
attack how do we change the when those
hearts and Minds so I I think it's
important to understand that at least to
me like one of the main reasons a lot of
people don't want freedom sorry a lot of
people don't want you to have freedom
it's because like Free People remind
people who don't want to be free to
their [__] right so
um so essentially like I I think that
the only way to do this is to create
absolute environments right so absolute
freedom environments like like master or
Bitcoin whatever uh and then we as
people who who interact with these
networks choose the extent in which we
want things to be free and also choose
the the people we want to interact with
and all those things like I mean humans
were not designed to to know what's
happening in every place of the world at
all times and talking to every kind of
culture in the world at all times right
I mean you lose your mind and that's why
like maybe as we do we'll allude it like
Twitter is angry because like we're just
not designed to have the fire holes into
our balls eyes of like this is all the
violence that's happening everywhere
it's like please stop you know I just
want to hang out with my friends at this
moment and say some stupid jokes you
know what I mean it's like it's like
we're having like a poker night and
we're gonna be offensive about certain
topics and I don't want to be judged
about those it's like everybody has
their your different sort of like safe
spaces right yeah you know sometimes I
just want to talk about end cap things
and I don't want kamis to come you know
like mess with my safe and capped space
um so it's just giving people both the
freedom to say and express themselves
absolutely but also having people have
ways to absolutely desegregate sort of
segregate themselves from that absolute
environment so uh can I ask does that
solve we touch on this a little bit but
does that solve you know let's call it
the child porn problem that you know the
response on Nostra is to child porn is
that you will not see it unless you want
to see it it's not that we're gonna
we're gonna hunt it down and get rid of
everybody or we're gonna report people
to the police uh you know on a
system-wide basis it is you know and I'm
not I I mean I think it's a hard line to
to push but I you know I I think there's
a lot of um a lot of validity in that
I mean it's a fair thing I mean like
screw them I mean these people are
horrific horrible human beings right I
mean there's a lot of horrific horrible
things in the world uh you know like you
can police your house yeah right so like
you can release your server you can
police your client uh to a certain
extent or to the extent it's
technologically possible Right but like
what people do in the world is not your
problem right I mean like you should
strive to get those pieces of [__] the
things that they deserve but like
you know that's that's the kind of
externality you have to sort out with
the people who participate in the
network how does like what are the in a
simple terms as possible what are the
mechanics of blocking from an individual
user basis I mean I know will mentioned
that that was kind of a an essential
part of getting past the the Apple Store
was implementing blocking but how does
that actually work since it's a it's an
open network how do you stop users from
interacting with your individual
key pair yeah so each user has uh their
public key and then so all you have to
do is you know I don't want to see any
messages from that key anymore
um and then you can just so that's what
the client does it just hides all the
messages from that key so if they're
posting it would be it would require the
client to just respect any of those
requests from the users and all the
incentives are probably going to be for
the clients to respect that request yeah
the idea is that the client is is on
your side to you know try to craft a
view of the network that you that you
prefer so it doesn't try to do anything
that you don't want it to do at least
that's my philosophy you don't have to
create a client that does that you can
create a client that's very opinionated
and tries to block people automatically
but the domus claims the only way to uh
you have full control over who what
you're allowed to see and what you don't
what you don't see yourself so for the
the last part of this conversation I
want to really talk a lot about the
relationship between Nostra and Bitcoin
and specifically the lightning Network
before we turn to that let me bring in a
couple more of the audience questions
one is from MC Wilde who gave 50 in some
sort of currency
regarding the client is it just pgp
implementation so that you just use your
key to self-custody your identity
connected to all your messages and if
you could translate that question for
you know uh the normal person that would
be helpful I think they're signaling Al
Qaeda but I'm not sure
um yeah I mean it's a it's a form of uh
just signing of you know cryptographic
signatures it's not using pgp per se
it's using something called libsecp
256k1 and this just happens to be the
library that Bitcoin uses for their keys
as well
um so we we use a lot of Technology from
Bitcoin which is which was cool
um but yeah it's very similar in that
sense that it's cryptographic keys but
it's a different type of key BTC pins
nvk orange Crocs or purple Crocs
uh uh why not both
[Laughter]
um train wreck is amethyst a legit
Nostra app
um and then it really helps though
because that's what I got on my phone
and I'll follow up with that question to
say if it is a legit and Oster app
what's the best way to put to you know
protect yourself and make sure that
you're not accidentally giving your
private keys out to a malicious actor
who's running you know a bad client
yeah so amethyst is a legit app um he's
doing a really good job he's probably
the best Android client right now
um but there is a risk you're putting
your private key into this client so if
they have some Rogue code in there that
just is stealing Keys you know you
probably wouldn't know that's happening
so that's that's kind of scary on the
web we have tools such as there's like
the lb plug-in and there's things where
you can put your private key into a
browser plug-in and it will hide it'll
protect your private key from the from
the browser apps which is really
important so if you're using web app
please use lb or another extension
um and in the future we have this thing
called net 26 which is going to allow
you to keep your root key private and
then use different keys for sending
messages so but that's that's up and
coming can I ask with uh you know I I
have an Android phone and I I've
downloaded amethyst I haven't put my
private key in it but should I not do
that or what do you do when you want to
use a phone based app
um and if you don't want to put your um
your key I I gave my keys to Damas so I
better be able to trust you uh you're
trusting me but it is open source so you
can go and check the code and see if I'm
doing anything bad but it doesn't mean
that I couldn't have changed the code
before I upload it right I'm not going
to say I did that I'm just saying it's
like it's definitely a thing you got to
think about which is why in the future
we're going to add this new feature
where you don't ever have to put that
private key in so that's gonna be fun
for advanced users so what what should I
do or what should amethyst use or should
they feel comfortable do you think uh
putting their private key into amethyst
if you don't feel comfortable you should
you can at least just create a new
account and then just play with it and
yeah in that in that way and then you
know but if you're it's probably fine
you know we're not like malicious we're
just trying to build this cool Network
it's mostly yeah I mean listen bugs
happen right yeah yeah like you know
like uh approach this is this is a big
experiment uh you know still like it's
early so you know don't use those keys
for your life savings like it's the same
idea too late too late right uh last
audience question here that I think you
both might have an answer to uh what
would you recommend for a learning
developer to learn as far as
decentralization where's a good place to
start
well decentralization is a pretty broad
term um so you could it could be like if
you want to get into Bitcoin and see how
like decentralized money works or if you
wanted to get into Nostra and see a
decentralized free speech Works
um you know whatever whatever tickles
you fancy just go down and let's start
reading some uh there's a lot of
resources online
um so I don't know I don't know what the
best answer is for that one you know
just learn how to code and then you're
gonna find ways of of finding
interesting things to work on just ask
just ask chat TPT and then that's right
um this is a post that you made uh will
zapping is a gesture along the lines of
I liked your post so much that I want
you to prosper more in this life that is
pretty strong zap equals love what does
it mean to zap someone some SATs on
Noster
yeah so
um a lot of most of the clients have a
way to integrate into the Bitcoin
lightning Network and it's it's very
fairly simple you just attach a
lightning address onto your profile and
that does that usually puts a little
lightning button on each post that you
can just send people some sets
um on the right bottom right here on
this post right yes I think I had a lot
of wine when I made that post I was
feeling like somewhat romantic or
something
um but uh it was it's it's true though
it's like you know you want us if you
see a post and you really like that
person like I'm happy to send some money
their way and like I want them to create
more content like that so you know it's
a gesture of Love sometimes likes are
cheap right likes uh require no proof of
work require nothing really like you
know we created the like Society in the
last 10 years and look where he got us
right so so this idea of you having even
though it's like nearly no economic
difference to you to send a few sides
um sats are essentially a small unit of
Bitcoin right um and we're talking uh
like a SAT could be as little as a penny
it's like a hundreds of thousands of a
penny yeah
um but it all like there is this bigger
thing that happens right you're actually
partying with something that is yours
right and you're giving it to somebody
because you did like their post so it's
not just this empty like Society uh you
also help with Spam right so people
can't game the the likes anymore uh uh
and the the retweets and things
um it's a at least in my view It's Like
A Better Way Forward uh we have this
with podcasts Now podcast 2.0 people can
send SATs and they can stream SAS to the
person they're listening to uh maybe
value for Value makes a way back yeah
you know for a while you know I I've
been somewhat of a skeptic of this micro
payments idea but uh it's so seamlessly
integrated on most through most of the
clients
um and uh it's a fascinating idea I mean
and it is fun you know some people have
been zapping me some stats is on my post
and it's you know maybe worth like a
dollar total or something but it's
exciting to see people you know engaging
in that way
um so and it also makes me think like
wow this really it could be a competitor
not only to something like Twitter but
maybe one day something like venmo
um like how integral was you know
putting
um uh you know Bitcoin and specifically
the lightning Network which is a second
layer on top of Bitcoin that you know
kind of speeds things up how integral
was that to the development of Noster
um I just think it
for me it's like
if I just created another Twitter and
just like replicated it it wouldn't be
that interesting to me so I was like
what can we do to make this like let's
just like amp it up to the next level
and make this really interesting and so
lighting I was working on Lightning at
the time just like as a protocol
developer I'm like let's just add this
because it's easy to kind of combine
protocols in that way and and yeah I
just I feel like there's something
happening on the network now which is is
really amazing to see just the people
sending money back and forth and you
know the other day I just like Zapped
someone a million satoshi's which was
like 400 I'm like I can't like that's
amazing like you can even do that on a
social network just like like zap bomb
people so you know adding economic
incentives to things tend to make them
better when it's the hard money right I
mean this is not the Fiat standard it's
the Bitcoin standard so
um you know you you create
people who care more about the things
that they're interacting with uh and I
think this is this is making a huge
difference on on this you know like will
said like you know just recreating tweet
twitter like you know it's totally
possible in Austria but then you arrive
at the same sort of horrible place
you're in uh and like yeah yeah and just
like and sending us that people just
seem like happier on the network because
you know there's so much love going
around if zap isn't love then there's so
much love going around on the network
and everyone's having a great time and
everyone I think everyone's just I think
the reason why everyone's so happy is
like there's like we have a path forward
into the future and people are really
hopeful and they now they know they
can't be censored they can't be you know
de-platformed and it's just like they
can just be themselves a big issue with
a lot of these Mastodon instances is I
was always self-centering myself because
I didn't want to say the wrong thing to
take off the admin to get banned but now
on this network they don't have to worry
about getting banned so people are just
being themselves and being happy and
being cool even though it's you know
it's kind of quirky and but it's it's
fun I mean it is easier to be happier
when you can't be censored right it's
you know it's the same with financial
transactions with Bitcoin like you just
you just don't self-censor yourself you
can be yourself uh you might even be
nicer too you might not be trying to
show a different thing because the
incentives are different can I ask uh
well I think you were talking about how
uh uh you know Jack Dorsey was talking
about this you know this is what Twitter
felt like when it had 5 000 users there
a lot of what you're talking about it
you know the early days of Twitter
um and as it became a global phenomena
phenomenon and a mass phenomenon it was
mostly people were really happy on it
you know and it helped underwrite or
supercharged the Arab Spring it brought
New Life to things you know boring worn
out shows like the NHL All-Star game or
the or the Academy Awards and things
like that is there a is there a a moment
when you could say definitively this is
when Twitter started to suck or are
there events you know that you are
worried about happening for Nostra that
will you know that won't make it sour I
have a theory and I think the big one is
the algorithm so I think the algorithm
is just making people unhappy even
though it's like boosting engagement
people are more engaged but it's like
engagement doesn't always mean it's like
good engagement it's like right um so I
think right now you know we reason a
couple of issues ago had a great story
uh cover story called in defensive
algorithms because you know a lot of
times people now talk about algorithms
like you know it's [__] zardas or a
Witch Hunt or something where you know
it's this evil Alien Force but you know
on its most basic level algorithms tend
to you know they're trying to push you
[__] that you like right but continue
please
yeah but like a lot of the way that
these like these machine learning
algorithms work is like it's they don't
really know if you really like it or if
it's having a good mental effect on on
your brain they just notice that you
click it more and so maybe like a lot of
times you'll just click it because it's
like this is pissing me off I want to
click I'm going to respond and that
would just register as like oh this is
an engagement this is great people are
interacting more but in reality is so
there's no there's no systems that
there's no algorithms that can like
detect if the user is happy or not
basically how they're using the system
at least from the from the perspective
of the actual machine learning algorithm
so will it be possible for relays to
implement those sort of algorithms uh
would they be using the nips to do that
uh yeah I mean it could definitely
create relays that sort of like the
Creed of certain feed the way that that
it wants it's kind of nice I mean like
you know you might not want to see every
repost you might not want to like see
every you know like some some words you
don't like you know what I mean like any
sometimes you can push some of that sort
of work to the relay or the clients can
do it too the clients are going to be
able to offer you a certain experience
that you prefer uh and in that very
libertarian manner you know you can vote
with your feet uh in your wallet are you
algorithms but sorry I say algorithm but
I'm actually about to implement one is
Adamas which is this is a very simple
one that just shows you all the top uh
Zapped posts so I don't know if that'll
be bad I don't know if it'll be maybe
but usually it's just like people are
sending money to a post they like it so
I'll see if that turns out bad or not
well that uh you know this is part of
the problem because then people are
going to be like oh that's getting a lot
of zaps I want to do that so they start
modeling off of that right
you do shape Behavior right uh but but
again like the problem that we have now
is that there's no choice right you have
Twitter you have Facebook you have
Instagram which is really Facebook uh
and and and Snapchat which talks about
because that's for my kids not for right
or Tick Tock or whatever right so but
you're stuck in the silences and you
don't have a choice of of like how you
want to interact with your friends your
network and and the world really right
or or news so like just being able to
choose clients based on honest or
dishonest in all the clients will do
what they're going to do and and
eventually you're going to find
experiences that that make you happy uh
or maybe you want to be miserable and
you choose a miserable app like I saw
that do you worry about you know well
what what's an event that could really
[__] things up as far as you're
concerned
that's like a it's hard to say because
it's one of those things where it's like
I wouldn't I can't really predict it
what what that would be
um yeah maybe this like you know we
start implementing algorithms just and
it just becomes just as bad as as
Twitter what I what I'm actually really
interested in looking into is this idea
of like a free market for algorithms so
maybe there's like some type of like
scripting language that all clients
might be able to implement and then you
can have like you can choose which
algorithms like bring stuff on your feed
and I think that'd be really interesting
this I don't think in many other social
networks are doing that right now so
you know there's only I'm only allowed
to have 100 people I follow at all times
on my app and I have to sort of like
make these awful decisions of like who
I'm gonna kick out to have a new one in
so it's just like Sophie's choice
I saw that um uh there was talk that
Twitter may be rolling out some sort of
Twitter coin that would replicate this
zap idea on Twitter where you reward
people with these Twitter tokens instead
of likes is Elon Musk uh feeling the
heat from Noster uh are you worried uh I
guess are you worried that basically
anything that succeeds over there is
just gonna be kind of absorbed by
Twitter or or is that kind of the goal
that you you want Noster ultimately to
be absorbed by a competitor like no musk
is going to use and I I've already
forgotten the name of what was
Facebook's uh crypto card
[Music]
you know you give a man a money a chance
to have a money printer he will use it
so you know like musk is just gonna
print his you know like Twitter [__]
coin and uh but these things lose value
right because you're gonna be stuck to
that thing you're gonna have to use kyc
to buy those the credit card you know
you sort of it's just remaking this
horrible environment but now you're
gonna have like Twitter cbdc right you
mean one twit coin doesn't equal one
twit coin what that's right I saw I
happen to see this comment down there
imagine thinking that Bitcoin can scale
laughing emoji
um and I only bring that up because
actually like seeing the kind of
seamless integration of Bitcoin by the
lightning Network on nostril makes me
think well actually this does seem like
it could scale
um how how worried or like what are the
big concerns for you in terms of scaling
it you know that does does big does the
integration of lightning cause any
scaling concerns um and then just you
know more and peop more and more people
uh jumping into the relays obviously
it's gonna you know slow things down at
times uh how do you deal with scaling
concerns say if if you know Noster you
know starts uh you know on an upward
huge upward trajectory after this stream
today
there is a lot of projects to scale
lightning uh there is also fediments uh
there's there's a lot going on in
scaling uh you know Noster is not the
only thing you know who knows maybe a
much bigger Network right now goes and
adds Bitcoin to it
um you know it is scalable there's
always going to be some snags along the
way uh because this is sort of like you
know Freedom attack right so somebody
has to go and build it uh there is no
big check from government hey here uh
scale disk to fake money right so
um the the thing is this kind of
criticism is a little annoying because
everything is working you know aside
from a snag here and there I mean like
we're here Bitcoin is running you know
Master is running the tips are flowing
um yeah since the lightning Network seem
to be a contradiction to bitcoin though
in the sense of you know the whole idea
is that you're doing peer-to-peer
disintermediated you know irreversible
irrevocable transactions and then the
first thing you got to do after a
certain number of people are using it is
oh put something on top no absolutely
not
um so lightning is just a different way
for you to transport the utxo then spent
transactions right it's just a more
efficient way to do that without having
to go back to a block but you you can
call that that say Capital at a chair
right at any time right so you can close
that channel and and there's penalties
if you don't people lose money if you
don't so uh no it's it's not it's not a
good sort of way of representing it uh
it is it is Bitcoin I think I see
lightning as like a clever way to use
Bitcoin transactions because all
lightning is it's like you you create
this Bitcoin transaction that you go
with multi-sig and then you just don't
broadcast to the chain and you're up
you're updating it um off to you and
it's just like it's just a smart way to
to do a to update a Bitcoin transaction
you know obviously in the white paper it
is a micro payment system I mean that's
the whole point or you know the original
statement but it does seem like once
you're you add any space I mean some you
know that's it's it presents the
possibility for funny business to be
happy you know that's that's the that's
the beautiful thing about the
cryptography is Magic right uh we can we
can do things of a fair degree of
certainty right like nothing is a
hundred percent right right but you can
do things with a certain degree of
certainty that that you can create sort
of like human transaction models on top
of it without being a real concern
can I ask I and I I want to turn it back
to uh Zach to follow up on on the
Bitcoin stuff but you know part of you
know part of what's happening with
Bitcoin and we saw this you know even uh
Gary Gensler you know who is nobody's
idea of a you know Frontiersman when it
comes to you know Financial transactions
or anything but he was saying you know
you gotta if you don't if you don't uh
own your keys you don't own your crypto
and things like that and it seems like
Nostra is coming out of the same mindset
where uh you know and a couple weeks ago
we had uh uh Powell on from Kraken uh
talking about
um you know like ultimately in his
favorite future there will be no uh
Bitcoin or you know there'll be no
crypto platforms because everybody will
own their own stuff
um are we going through a phase here a
kind of phase change that Bitcoin maybe
is like the first part of like where
people really do have to kind of own up
and understand the technology they're
using on some basic level but also take
responsibility
um you know and I I mean not to get too
grandiose about it but if you know what
happened in the enlightenment was that
individuals ultimately were given you
know or they weren't given they took it
they stole it from the powers that be
but they insisted on having more control
over their lives and more responsibility
are we are we in the beginning stage of
another broad-based shift where
individuals were pulling back
information we're pulling back our
identity we're pulling back power from
these large corporations or states that
have been saying no we are we're running
things you don't get to choose you know
if you if you have your own private keys
I mean any person right now in the world
that can remember 12 words could travel
naked with all their uh money all their
wealth right and there's absolutely
nothing a state actor can do aside from
killing them right they won't even know
that they have it so I think you'll take
like another 20 30 years uh first dead
actors to get around that and understand
that productive people are going to have
to be offered uh better terms in order
to to stay with their Capital so
everything that goes around this new
sort of dynamic right of of actual
through ownership is the first property
you can actually own right without state
enforcement so uh it's a paradigm shift
it really is and Noster is the same for
identity uh and in a network
that's very fast I just want to I you
know I want to travel with somebody who
is carrying you know all of their wealth
you know and as we just cross border and
border and they're like whispering to
themselves there don't forget it please
don't forget yeah no but I mean I I love
that Vision I think it's one of the most
absolutely captivating ideas of a future
that is you know is just like in
insanely free and autonomous
um so
I repeat my 24 words to myself every day
just like in my head just just in case I
need to escape the country yeah I I uh
so just close out the conversation I
want to talk about something will was
alluding to early on that social media
is really kind of just the beginning of
the vision for Nostra and um this post
from nvk says uh Bitcoin is distributed
Noster can be centralized decentralized
realized and distributed all at the same
time for different interactions slash
content nbk could you explain first of
all what is the difference between say
decentralized and distributed and then
talk more broadly about the point you're
making here about Nostra and kind of the
the possibilities Beyond just social
media so like Bitcoin is almost a
literal opposite of not certain topology
so in Bitcoin everybody has to be in the
exact consensus of The Ledger and every
single participant has a full copy of
their Ledger I mean real participants if
you have your coins on coinbase you're
not a bitcoiner coinbase is a Bitcoin
you're in your name right but in the
distributed map right you notice that
every single node is connected to every
node you could draw that same analogy
right not that everybody's actually
connected but the idea is everybody has
a copy of the same exact thing we all
agree that that is exactly the same
thing through proof of work right and
that's Bitcoin
um
now on on Noster uh relays uh in in
clients and users they have a
many-to-many relationship right and they
can even have slightly outer versions of
the network itself not everything but
you know there is things you don't
necessarily have to agree on you might
actually even fall off consensus say for
example you're using the nips in a
different way it's not ideal it's not a
good use of the network but is this
possible and you may find other network
players that also want to use this
slightly variant version of the network
um it just means that you may not talk
to each other anymore right you become
decentralized and you may have points uh
bridges that make sort of like interface
between the two is inefficient but but
what I'm just trying to represent here
is that there is a freedom for that
right
and and on author you can also have this
private relationships too you can have
your private relay that just keeps
backups of all the interactions you have
with all the relays right they're all
the relays may not have full visibility
on all your notes
so you may choose to send cat pictures
to cat pictures Society Relay groups you
may choose to send you know like uh uh
you know long-form articles to some
other place
um and and you can keep this thing
separate on how you interact with the
whole universe right uh but then you can
have like different ways to interact
with some of them that may be more
private less private it can have company
relays that only see like employees of
Google have access to uh so that's
essentially what I'm trying to explain
uh these two things are completely
separate but they use very similar uh
preambles of of like Freedom style uh uh
networks and how about you will what
what is the what is what are your
wildest dreams of where this heads you
know in the long term
yeah so the way that I see these relays
is that they're like they're free speech
nodes in cyberspace and you can interact
with them in different ways and they can
have different access levels
um so you might maybe you would have
like one like like mvk was saying one
within your organization and it's
private to your organization
um but it's actually much more General
than just speech um so this is not sure
as notes and stuff transmitted over
relays it's not just speech and stuff
you know so you could have application
data that is transmitted and censorship
resistant for different use cases
um you can you can build applications
someone built like a chess application
on top of Nostra
um so what what nausea really represents
to me is like
um it's like a generalization of the web
uh specifically for interoperable
applications and that's the one thing
that the web lacks is that you yeah you
can go to a website and you have all
yourself in that one website but they
don't talk to other websites so Nostra
is like this you know this system that
is like everything can interoperate and
that we we we're just starting to see
what what's possible with that like we
don't even know where this is gonna go
but it's really exciting so there is a
bounty sorry uh for 300 000 right now
for somebody to build a alternative to
GitHub using Noster so git is a
decentralized protocol already right for
you to write software where it keeps
Version Control right uh because that is
text-based you can actually sort of send
those commits via Noster and somebody
just has to build sort of like you know
a client that sort of takes advantage of
that yeah what I would love to see uh is
you know I've just this has just been on
my mind lately with the uh kind of
rolled doll rewrites where they went
back and kind of uh excise problematic
passages from his books
um I would like to see some sort of
blockchain based solution to kind of
censorious revision of like historical
Works um and it does I mean Noster seems
like a potential route for that because
it you know it's obviously can handle
text-based uh
um information
um but yeah that's it's a really
interesting Vision that that you uh
sketch out there will um I would love
that type of stuff for literary Works in
general because you know I mean authors
as well as corporate authors you know
change stuff all the time the Hardy Boys
we read today is not the same Hardy Boys
from 1980 or 1930.
um and to be able to see that kind of
and toggle in between but even you know
even uh you know short story writers
like Raymond Carver radically rewrote
their stories over time and the question
is whether that's going to happen it's
how do you make it visible so and how do
you give both the reader and the writer
control I think
yeah well
you guys real quickly you know you're
you're you know how did you come into
not simply obviously coding and stuff
like that but being libertarian because
you know we started this uh conversation
with a a clip from a great doc that's
acted only a few years ago with Corey
doctorow you know the Corey doctorow
that we're getting in 2023 is not the
same Corey doctorate we were getting in
you know 2003
um you know uh well why don't you start
like where where did your world view
um come from and and what are your
commitments
yeah I was like very politically
ignorant and like and just like
philosophically ignorant I was just a
computer nerd and I just like building
software and then and then I discovered
Bitcoin and I started talking a lot of
bitcoiners and I started asking like
what is money and the minute I went down
that rabbit hole that's like you should
have asked what is a woman
right I know but then I instantly like
yeah that ice basically became
libertarian overnight and just and
that's been kind of because I just find
that a fascinating topic like what is
money and and how Bitcoin fixes so many
issues in our society
um yeah anyway that's guys that was
where I came from
um how old are you will
I am 34. okay and uh nvk
I I'm a product of the early internet
yeah
um and uh you know Hocking School and
crap like that uh but I was very
confused politically uh you know I'm of
a you know generation where
um you know we were trying to seek a
better world through uh through very
confused ideas uh and I I think Bitcoin
and like you know when I found Bitcoin
uh understanding money similar path uh
it's just it crystallizes right because
money is everything is where the
incentives come from is where Freedom it
truly is made it's information yeah yeah
you know and and sort of like that that
shaped uh that shaped my uh my last uh
my last 14 years uh how old are you mvk
if you uh um I'm 40. okay this year you
are ancient anxious right the early
internet Pioneer uh do you guys see then
you're both in Zach you're what 38 38 38
yeah 38. so I I you know I I speak here
as like you know [__] Charlton Heston
and planted the apes or something but do
you I mean you guys as
um you know as representatives of of
millennial and and actually yeah right
well you're still no no I refuse I'm On
the Border no you're not you're I'm
sorry you're a millennial no no no we've
checked with the uh you know the powers
that be but is there
um you know I mean there's a real
interesting kind of split right
generationally where you know certain
Millennials are very uh you know you
know they want to be protected they want
the trusted third party to do everything
uh and then there seems to be you know a
growing you know or or a flip of that
um is you know can can you speak to that
and is Bitcoin you know is Bitcoin the
way uh and and a kind of distributed
decentralized future uh one that's you
know where individuals are really
talking about having more control of
more autonomy over their decisions
um you know is Bitcoin helping to make
that a reality or is it just going to
harden a kind of divide between
collectivists and kind of arch
individualists so I grew up in Brazil
right and and I had my savings removed
from me with bayodians I oversaw four
currency collapses uh in our society is
completely broken down economically
socially like everything with all the
natural resources you know all the usual
Brazilian problems and
you know like at least in Brazil like
you don't see young people being as
naive and as sort of uh
you know Kami uh like the champagne Kami
as we call them uh they're not champagne
socialists like here uh in North America
I mean you know maybe it's just a
product of life it's just too easy and
now you have like you know Pizza porn
video games and in your parents basement
so people people
don't find responsibility because they
don't have to you know your generation
and the generation before you like kids
would start working at like you know 15
but actually working I I can tell you
I'm like like you I'm at the end of the
baby boom it's like no it's like my
[__] life and I I grew up lower
middle class my life was easy
particularly compared to my parents who
grew up in the depression so maybe it
just but that's it it really is just a
it's a product of responsibility right
of like being forced to have
responsibility at least in my view so
like Bitcoin once you you get into
Bitcoin you sort of like you truly it
clicks for most people that are in it
that like there's clown world out there
is all designed to exist and just sort
of like boring from your future uh and
and that's the money opportunity cost
problem that you you can't find it you
can't price your life in Fiat and you
get into Bitcoin you're like holy crap
you know I have responsibility over my
money now and and and I can't build
things on the future because you know
the Bitcoin price sort of appreciating
this specific distribution schedule
because the the scarcity thing
um uh the inflation is is set right so
uh provided that this project works like
you know you're building your future
based on this on this very strong
pillars uh that has like you know over a
decade now of sort of like working so I
I don't know I think that's why like it
doesn't matter which generation you are
you find Bitcoin and you clearly like
very clearly in in very uh fast you snap
into the a more Hayek or or sort of uh
uh uh version of the world
well do you have a anything
uh pretty much everything that mvk said
I don't think I have anything extra
after that let me uh let's uh wrap up
with just these last few audience
questions
um and then get out of here one is from
a non-atterlin I fear human nature will
always lead to isolated Islands on the
internet like how Mastodon is turning
out to be
um I mean I I tend to think the opposite
actually that the Human Nature has shown
that people love to jump into a big uh
Network where they have a huge audience
like Twitter or Facebook and kind of
maximize their connections but does
anyone else have thoughts on that's that
concept of echo Chambers Islands I think
there's room for both I think you can
um so I think dust really supports
different different use cases and it can
really enable hey if you want to hang
out with your smaller communities you
can do that if you want to reach a wider
audience you can do that and I think
that makes sense I don't think being
like always in the global audiences
always a good thing so just providing
options I think is a better situation
says Zach I love that you're big on this
right now and have plenty of zaps in
your wallet uh Yale was the one who got
me looking into Noster so thank you you
know it's a it's a really fascinating
um space
um MC Wilde 11 again says where it's
data stored how our message is tied to
private key are there limits to data
types
um maybe that just the last question
here is worth addressing any web with
technical documentation you can point us
to so just people who want to know more
about the underlying protocol what do
they do
so you can go to the uh our GitHub it's
the Nostra Dash protocol slash uh nips
and that will give you all the protocol
documentation you can also just go to
nostradesh protocol slash Nostra and
it'll give you a really good overview of
like why this exists and why it's cool
um yeah and for the other questions the
messages are sort of the relays and
they're signed by your key and yeah
and um
yeah so can I ask so like if a real
light disappears
does your mat do your messages disappear
with it then potentially yeah if you're
not having them somewhere else too so
this is why you connect to like more
than one like if you're just connected
to one you just you're basically Twitter
um so you want to connect like 10 and
then every time you do a post it'll send
it to all those relays at the same so
this is it's all Harry Potter right this
is all we're in like a horcrux age where
we're taking ourselves and kind of it's
not an exact metaphor but we're
spreading ourselves around in different
places so that when we really need it we
can go retrieve ourselves yeah I mean in
time you're going to see paid services
to Archive your stuff you know again
it's uh these are all problems they're
still not present right because we're
still all experimenting and having fun
but as people try to do things with like
higher economic incentive right uh like
Solutions come yeah yeah
well thank thank you guys this was a
great conversation I'm putting up uh you
can follow all of us on Nostra uh
there's the uh handles you can use yeah
that's either by public key or my
cholesterol in some kind of binary code
I don't know but thank you yeah that you
can copy uh Nick's long public key uh
from the text below uh or for the rest
of us just copy those uh addresses to
find us on there
um thank you uh will thank you nvk
thanks Nick um thank you to best buyers
our backstage producer and uh also to
everyone who tuned in will be back here
next Thursday at one o'clock
thanks